die 100 fast voll vor dem corona gipfel
am montag erreicht der deutsche
incidents werten 99,9 und die politik
diskutiert lebhaft über notbremsen
rückschlag für frauenrechte
die türkei tritt aus einem
internationalen abkommen gegen gewalt an
frauen aus die empörung ist riesig
heißer gruß aus dem erdkern nach 900
jahren pause spuckte ein abgelegener
vulkan auf island beeindruckende
lavafontänen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten am samstag der sport
kommt heute von norbert könig und wieder
wartet das land auf die signale die am
montag aus berlin kommen sollen nach dem
bund und länder zur coroner lage getagt
haben da entscheidet sich mehr oder
weniger verbindlich wie es vor allem an
ostern aussehen wird und so wie sich die
pandemie derzeit entwickelt gerät statt
der erhofften lockerung zusehens die
notbremse in den fokus denn die korona
zahlen steigen kontinuierlich
das robert koch institut meldet 16.000
33 neue infektionen innerhalb eines
tages 3359 mehr als vergangenen samstag
207 menschen starben
in verbindung mit cupid 19 bundesweit
stieg die inzidenz auf 99,9 einen blick
auf die deutschlandkarte zeigt immer
mehr regionen werden rot hier liegt die
inzidenz wieder über 100 der kritischen
marke ab der eine notbremse greifen soll
oliver deuker berichtet hamburg mit
festen terminen shoppen gehen bis
gestern war das noch möglich weil die
inzidenz auf drei aufeinanderfolgenden
tagen über 100 lag zog der stadtstaat
nun die notbremse bestellen abholen ja
reingehen anprobieren nein dialogue
darum und das ist auch nicht mehr lustig
die ziehen die wirtschaft noch weiter in
den keller
wegen bundesweit steigender instanzen
unterstützt auch bayerns
ministerpräsident markus söder diesen
schritt zitat weitere öffnungen ergeben
angesichts der erneut steigenden
infektion keinen sinn die notbremse muss
für alle gelten und zwar konsequent
borkum seit fast fünf monaten dürfen die
hoteliers hier wie überall in
deutschland keine touristen empfangen
laufende kosten aber keine einnahmen sie
brauchen gäste jetzt sie brauchen das
ostergeschäft dass das wichtige geld was
wir nach dem langen winter brauchen
wirtschaftlich wird es jetzt irgendwann
ziemlich schwierig weil wir haben auch
ostern gehofft
so oft das beherbergungsgewerbe von den
alpen bis zur nordsee auf den kommenden
montag hofft auflockerungen doch danach
sieht es derzeit nicht aus
der spielraum dass man weiter lockert
der ist wirklich sehr gering das müssen
alle wissen und deswegen rate ich auch
wirklich dazu nicht zu große hoffnungen
an die nächste runde zwischen
bundeskanzlerin und regierungschefs und
scheffelten der länder zu richten
keine großen hoffnungen also
auflockerungen wäre denn aber ein oster
urlaub unter bestimmten umständen
vorstellbar
aus der urlaub ja in den ferienwohnungen
osterurlaub jahr verwandtenbesuch im
idealfall oder freunde besuchen im
idealfall eben lange zeiträume wenig
verschiedene personen aber die intensiv
treffen schwierig ist alles um viele
menschen trifft das ist dann im zweifel
die zugfahrt dorthin das ist im zweifel
das flugzeug das ist im zweifel eben die
hotellobby oder restaurant
speisegaststätten etc
das sehen mallorca touristen aus
deutschland wohl anders was ist richtig
was ist falsch infektionsschutz oder die
wirtschaft wieder stärken keine leichte
entscheidung
bei demonstrationen gegen korona
maßnahmen in kassel ist es zu massiven
auseinandersetzungen zwischen
verschiedenen gruppen und der polizei
gekommen
von den rund 20.000 sogenannten
querdenker innen hielten sich viele
nicht an die auflage mund und
nasenschutz zu tragen
die polizei setzte schlagstöcke und
pfefferspray ein
mehrere menschen wurden festgenommen
nach brasilien wo sich derzeit so viele
menschen mit corona anstecken wie in
keinem anderen land
rund 90.000 neue infektionen wurden
gestern gezählt und dabei wird
vergleichsweise wenig getestet
die zahl der toten steigt und steigt auf
jetzt mehr als zweieinhalbtausend pro
tag und die lage droht sich weiter zu
verschlimmern denn in den krankenhäusern
sind nahezu alle intensivbetten belegt
christa fritzsche rat
es wird wieder geimpft in rio de janeiro
zwischenzeitlich war der impfstoff
ausgegangen
eigentlich sollte die gruppe der über 70
jährigen längst durch sein
doch das impfprogramm brasiliens liegt
im zeitplan zurück ich hätte diese
impfung schon vor monaten bekommen
sollen aber mit der ineffizienz dieser
regierung schleppen wir uns dahin
es gibt zu wenig impfstoff die
versäumnisse der regierung werden immer
offensichtlicher präsident ball szenario
der weiter wissenschaftliche vorgaben
ablehnt wechsel zwar zum vierten
gesundheitsminister während der pandemie
doch ein grundlegender kurswechsel ist
nicht zu erwarten
das impfprogramm ist ins stocken geraten
gleichzeitig schlagen in allen
landesteilen die ärzte alarm das
gesundheitswesen befindet sich im
zusammenbruch die pandemie breitet sich
aus in einem nie dagewesenen tempo es
ist ein wettlauf um leben und tod
denn es geht um mehr als nur brasilien
experten warnen dass die ungebremste
ausbreitung des virus in dem riesigen
land zur gefahr für die ganze welt
werden könnte
es sei nur eine frage der zeit bis hier
eine variante entstünde die gegen die
bekannten impfungen resistent sei die
internationale gemeinschaft muss sich
mobilisieren viel mehr initiative zeigen
und sei es nur im eigenen interesse denn
brasilien ist heute der ort auf der welt
mit der größten wahrscheinlichkeit dafür
dass varianten entstehen die für die
ganze welt gefährlich sein können schon
jetzt dominiert hier die anscheinend
gefährlichere virusvariante p1 das
infektionsgeschehen doch anstatt
entschlossen zu handeln bleiben die
schutzmaßnahmen stückwerk in rio haben
am wochenende die strände geschlossen
doch sonst gibt es kaum einschränkungen
das virus ist außer kontrolle
in brasilien
auch polen hat stark steigende
infektionszahlen deshalb hat die
bundesregierung das land als hoch
incidents gebiet eingestuft einreisen
darf ab morgen nur wer einen negativen
corona test vorzeigen kann
in polen gelten seit heute wieder
strengere corona maßnahmen für
mindestens drei wochen bleiben die
meisten läden museen kinos und hotels
geschlossen
schüler und schülerinnen lernen wieder
per fernunterricht gewalt gegen hunderte
jahre 100 jahre lang war er im
dornröschenschlaf vergangenen nacht ist
er spektakulär erwacht auf island ist
der vulkan vater als fidel ausgebrochen
er liegt im südwesten der insel rund 40
kilometer entfernt von der hauptstadt
reykjavik in unbewohntem gebiet über
hunderte von metern tat sich die
oberfläche des berges auf und er spuckte
lavafontänen in den nachthimmel
ein beeindruckendes naturspektakel
hermann berg die austretende lover
verfärbt den himmel über island glutrot
sind spektakuläre bilder aus der
vergangenen nacht lavafontänen treten
aus rissen in der erde aus nahe des
berges verkehr der als für bewohnte
gebiete bestehe keine große gefahr so
die behörden
es handle sich um einen eher kleinen
ausbruch seit monaten hatte es tausende
erdbeben in der region gegeben für
experten klare hinweise in dieser
auspuff wirklich keine überraschung die
ganze nation hatte wochenlang mit
angehaltenem atem darauf gewartet das
hat sich schon lange hingezogen vor etwa
15 monaten stiegen die seismischen
aktivitäten in der region deutlich an
mehr als 32 aktive vulkane gibt es auf
island man gewöhnt sich daran sagen sie
in der ortschaft kinder weg dort sind
viele in der nacht unterwegs um das
spektakuläre naturereignis nichts zu
verpassen
es gab es hier starke erdbeben in den
letzten zwei wochen so war man
vorbereitet auf das was passieren würde
es werden erinnerungen wach an den
ausbruch des vulkans eyjafjallajökull
der 2010 den kompletten europäischen
flugverkehr lahmlegte
danach sieht es derzeit nicht aus gewalt
gegen frauen ist in der türkei ein
verbreitetes problem
nach angaben von
frauenrechtsorganisationen wurden allein
im vergangenen jahr mindestens 300
frauen in der türkei von männern
ermordet
etwa dreimal so viele wie in deutschland
trotz dieser bilanz ist präsident
erdogan heute aus der internationalen
istanbul konvention ausgetreten
sie verpflichtet staaten dazu alle
formen von gewalt gegen frauen und
mädchen als verbrechen einzustufen
jörg brase finger weg von der konvention
rufen sie die meisten von ihnen haben
die ganze nacht nicht geschlafen
kurz nach mitternacht hatte sich die
nachricht verbreitet sofort wurden
protestaktionen im ganzen land
organisiert die istanbuler konvention
sollte uns frauen vor häuslicher gewalt
schützen
es war eine internationale vereinbarung
die weiterging als unsere nationalen
gesetze und es ist verheerend dass diese
konvention von einem einzigen mann außer
kraft gesetzt wird
in der vergangenen nacht hatte das
amtsblatt die entscheidung präsident
erdogan veröffentlicht aus der istanbul
konvention auszusteigen am frauentag
erst hatte erdogan erklärt zentrum
seiner politik sei die familie und die
konvention einen angriff auf diese
institution im westen zerbrechen die
familien weil die frauen von ihren
familien entfremdet werden und nun
versuchen sie uns dieses spiel ebenfalls
aufzuzwingen
familienministerin selcuk verteidigte
die entscheidung auf twitter die
türkischen gesetze böten frauen
ausreichend schutz und könnten bei
bedarf erweitert werden
doch frauenrechtlerinnen kritisieren die
juristische praxis in der türkei die
frau bittet um polizeischutz bekommt ihn
aber nicht der täter kommt später frei
und ermordet die frau und einige
gerichte weisen ihr dann sogar die
schuld zu weil sie sich nicht gegen
diese gewalt gewertet
für ihren kampf um frauenrechte in der
türkei ist die entscheidung des
präsidenten ein schwerer schlag
es ist ja kaum vorstellbar dass erdogan
gewalt gegen frauen gut heißt hier base
in istanbul
warum dann aber diese entscheidung nun
die mag sicher auch sinkenden
umfragewerten von erdogans regierender
partei geschuldet sein die entscheidung
aus der konvention auszutreten es sicher
auch ein zeichen an seine konservative
stammwählerschaft aber auch an andere
konservative streng islamische kreise
von denen nämlich war die forderung
erhoben worden aus der konventionen
auszutreten
die sehen darin einen angriff auf die
traditionelle türkische familie und
sehen darin auch eine beförderung von
ehescheidungen das mag auch der meinung
des präsidenten entsprechen der
gelegentlich solche entscheidungen
trifft die auf diese wählergruppen ziele
wie zum beispiel auch die im vergangenen
jahr die hagia sophia von einem museum
wieder zu einer moschee zu machen solche
entscheidungen sind innenpolitisch
motiviert kritik aus dem ausland
interessiert den präsidenten dabei
relativ wenig danke für die erklärung
wir preise wie viel normalität können
wir dem corona virus abtrotzen wieviel
begegnung wie viel kultur ist möglich
die berliner bühnen wagen jetzt ein
pilotprojekt in den großen häusern wie
der staatsoper der volksbühne dem
konzerthaus und anderen finden einzelne
vorstellungen statt premiere war gestern
mit getesteten publikum im berliner
ensemble
die stadt will herausfinden wie groß das
risiko solcher veranstaltungen ist heute
abend geht's weiter in der philharmonie
christhard läpple berichtet in nicht
einmal drei minuten war die philharmonie
ausverkauft dieser test war erfolgreich
die 1000 glücklichen staaten stunden
lang für den eigentlichen test an motto
erst zum abstrich dann zu romeo und
julia von tschaikowsky berlin wartet den
trubel start
die welt schaut jetzt auch berlin auch
nicht nur aus dem kulturbereich auch
viele menschen aus dem sport alle die
mit veranstaltungen zu tun haben und was
wir hier zeigen ist dass man zu sagen
mit gutem hygiene konzept zuzüglich
testungen der veranstaltung durch hören
kann im kammermusiksaal das testzentrum
start small talk vor dem event ein
stäbchen im rachenraum das ergebnis
kommt aufs handy ist der schnelltest
negativ steht einem echten höhepunkt
nichts mehr entgegen
das erste live konzert der berliner
philharmoniker seit gefühlten ewigkeiten
am dirigentenpult kirill petrenko 30.000
karten wünsche gab es doch jeder zweite
platz muss gesperrt bleiben abstand im
schachbrettmuster und mundschutz heißt
die devise egal
die berliner haben schon so viel
überstanden und sie lieben ihre
philharmoniker
[Musik]
ich freue mich auch ein paar bemerkungen
dazu machen zu können warum wir jetzt
hier sind während in ganz deutschland
alles zu ist denn das ist natürlich auch
eine schwierige situation der entstehen
auch natürlich so was wie sehnsüchte
auch verständlicher neid
wir sind noch nicht in der situation die
kultureinrichtung zur eröffnung aber die
probieren aus der abend kostet 20 euro
inklusive schnelltest das berliner
pilotprojekt läuft bis ostern
dann soll es erste ergebnisse geben
ja auch im sport steht heute das thema
publikum im mittelpunkt die olympischen
spiele in tokio werden ohne ausländische
fans stattfinden
das gilt natürlich auch für die
paralympics die entscheidung sei
bedauerlich aber unvermeidlich heißt es
aus dem organisationskomitee die
sicherheit für die teilnehmenden und die
japanische bevölkerung habe oberste
priorität
olympischer und paralympischer sport aus
tokio für den rest der welt an fernseh
ereignis einreiseverbot für ausländische
olympia fans in einer pandemie die
organisationschefin wir mussten diese
entscheidung treffen
sie war unvermeidlich und es ist ein
trauriger tag
auch wenn die entscheidung keine
zuschauer international zuzulassen
vernünftig ist und die olympischen
spiele auf keinen fall zu einem globalen
treiber der pandemie werden dürfen ein
virus schließt olympia türen auch für
die familien der athleten und
athletinnen der ioc präsident bach wir
wissen dass es ein großes opfer für
jeden ist somit müssen für die spiele
und die paralympics 630.000 verkaufte
ticket zurückerstattet werden kosten von
mehr als eine halbe milliarde euro die
frage bleibt wie viele sportbegeisterte
einwohner japans dürfen nun überhaupt im
stadion noch zuschauen
im rahmen eines pilotprojekts durften im
ostseestadion 777 fans das
drittliga-spiel von hansa rostock gegen
den halleschen fc verfolgen
mit dem 1 0 durch das tor von ferro
haben die hanseaten platz zwei
verteidigt die partie vor corona
getesteten fans wurde genehmigt weil die
sieben tage incidents in rostock seit
monaten unter 50 und aktuell bei 22,9
liegt ohne fans in der arena hat bayern
münchens torjäger robert lewandowski
seine bundesliga saisontreffer 33 bis 35
gefeiert
am ende steht ein 4 0 gegen den vfb
stuttgart eintracht frankfurt weiter
erfolgreich 5 zu 2 gegen union berlin
hollern sichert dortmund kurz vor
schluss mit seinem zweiten tor das 2 2
in köln und wolfsburg gewinnt in bremen
2 1 am abend schalke 04 gegen
mönchengladbach ralf rangnick hat heute
das jobangebot als sportdirektor
schalke abgelehnt gestern bielefeld
leipzig null zu eins von den fünf top
teams hat nur dortmund punkte abgegeben
wolfsburg beim stichwort champions
league qualifikation schon acht punkte
vor dem fünften dem bvb 09
leverkusen könnte mit der borussia
gleichziehen zwischen platz 14 und 17
bleibt es sehr eng die letzten drei
härter mainz und schalke warten noch auf
ihre ergebnisse im aktuellen sportstudio
um 23 uhr ist union berlins torhüter
andreas luthe zu gast und alexander
zverev steht im endspiel des atp tennis
turniers in acapulco er gewinnt gegen
dominik koepfer das deutsche
halbfinal-duell in zwei sätzen
dominik koepfer im vordergrund spielte
auf augenhöhe gegen alexander zverev der
den ersten satz mit 6 zu 4 für sich
entschieden hatte im zweiten ging es
sogar in den tie-break ein kurzes
erdbeben sorgte zwischenzeitlich für
unruhe in acapulco
es wäre nach gut zwei stunden mit 7 zu 6
das match für sich entschied und nun im
finale auf den griechen zieht sie passt
trifft das was mit worten ja dank
genauer wird jetzt zu einem vogel der
als rabauke unter seinen artgenossen
gilt das rotkehlchen soeben zum vogel
des jahres gewählt der nur 18 gramm
leichte vogel mit der rötlichen kehle
verteidigt sein revier unerschrocken
gegen konkurrenten
trotzdem ist der menschen gegenüber
zutrauliche als andere vögel die wahl
gibt es bereits seit 50 jahren erstmals
stimmte aber nicht die fachwelt ab
sondern 460.000 tierfreunde der sonntag
zeigt sich morgen auf trüb mit regen und
schnee an der ostsee aber auch so nicht
die einzelheiten hat gleich katja
honnefer so viele von uns für heute
claus kleber freut sich auf die im heute
journal um viertel vor elf und wir
freuen uns wenn sie morgen auch
einschalten 19 uhr bis dahin einen
schönen samstagabend matches